[Musique]
ces murs anonymes ont traversé les
siècles mais son nom résonne jusqu'au
japon
la ferme de flagey c'est un peu la
matrice de gustave courbet de sa
peinture et de son goût pour les
paysages de sa terre natale de sa
naissance peau de traces mais une
légende
le trajet de sa mère sylvie vers ornans
un chaos de la charrette et peut-être
une contraction de trop l'enfant n'est
sur le chemin c'est la maison paternelle
du peintre gustave courbet bien entendu
puisque ses parents
régis et sylvie son épouse sont décédées
dans cette maison puisqu'ils sont à
l'état civil de flash et déjà des
notables à l'époque n'étaient pas bons
on voit pas courber allait prendre la
pelle puis la pioche pour aller
travailler les champs à la mort des
parents juliette la jeune soeur de
gustave hérite du domaine est le cédrat
en 1910 peu avant sa mort à son métayer
sans toucher ou presque à la chambre du
maître la famille bourgon l'occupera
près de 90 ans nous sommes ici dans la
chambre de gustave courbet donc il y
venait de temps en temps ici en revenant
de paris et il aimait beaucoup se
retrouver à flagey vue sur le jardin vue
sur la côte où il parlait des
framboisiers de la côte de renier qu'il
allait cueillir ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que c'est la maison d'enfance de
l'usaf courbet ici et il ne l'a jamais
potes il l'a jamais représenté il en
parle paraît comme s'ils n'existaient
pas pour lui alors effectivement il n'y
a aucune peinture aucune trace de aussi
bien du jardin que de la maison par
contre il ya de nombreux écrits où il
parle de sa maison de cela j'ai un et
deux du plateau et voilà un
là on situe bien quand même qu'il aimait
beaucoup flagelle qu'il revenait céder à
la communauté de communes puis revendu
un euro symbolique au conseil
départemental
la maison sera restaurée à partir de
2005 pour redevenir un lieu de vie
dès 2003 va naître un projet de profiter
un petit peu de la figure de gustave
courbet pour se lancer dans le projet
pays de courbet pays d'artiste à partir
je crois de 2005
1 c'est à dire essayer de faire résonner
autour de quelques sites emblématiques
comme dernier atelier gustave courbet à
ornans le musée bien évidemment tu es
déjà propriété du département depuis
1971 la ferme courbet ici est également
les sentiers de randonnées plus les
aménagements de la source donald au fil
des concerts des expos des rencontres
artistiques dans ses chambres d'hôtes ou
son jardin pédagogique
depuis dix ans la ferme de flagey a su
prendre sa place dans le paysage qu'on 3
et le choeur des visiteurs elle sera au
centre du bicentenaire de la naissance
de courbet en 2019